I spoke last week with Angelo caruson
from Media Matters and we talked about
the escape hatch that right-wing media
and many Republicans have set up for
themselves when it comes to Donald Trump
in 2024. it looks as though the Murdoch
family through news corporations the New
York Post is pulling the ripcord on the
escape hatch publishing a front page
piece Trump de Dumpty depicting Donald
Trump as a swollen-headed Humpty Dumpty
saying Don who couldn't build the wall
had a great fall can all the gop's men
put the party back together again this
is a piece it's an opinion piece in the
New York Post by John pedorets and John
pedoritz calls the piece here's how
Donald Trump sabotaged the Republican
midterms or whoever picked the title
called it that often it's not the writer
and points out that Donald Trump has had
three consecutive elections in which he
has arguably been a drag if not a
downright disaster for the Republican
Party think of it Donald Trump won the
presidency in 2016 riding on a number of
different things that included of course
James Comey opting to do a second press
conference to talk about Hillary Clinton
for some reason we still haven't figured
out and many other factors Trump won in
2016 genuinely he really won
2018 didn't go nearly as well for
Republicans as historically maybe it
should have
2020 Trump straight up lost and they
lost everything they lost the house the
Senate and the and the White House in
2020 and now in 2022 I know Trump is
saying oh I'm 215. I have two 200
endorsements I got right and 15 I got
wrong but as I've told you before
it's very easy to run up the score when
you're mostly endorsing incumbents and
republican nominees in safe red
districts but on the critical races that
would make a difference Michigan
Governor Pennsylvania Governor
Pennsylvania Senate
um Georgia Senate we have the list right
um Trump's record is not very good in
2022 and Rupert Murdoch and his family
seem to be saying we're out couple
different things that are important to
think about here my concern with all of
this I don't really care I don't care at
all about the Murdoch family news
corporation Fox News the internal
deliberations of the Republican Party
Ronald McDaniel I don't care about any
of these people I think they're all
horrible I think it's a misguided
movement my concern is what would be the
most damaging scenario to themselves how
can they themselves damage themselves
the most
is it Trump announces on Tuesday that
he's running for president and everybody
gets out of the way
does that now lead to two years of human
further humiliation and another big loss
in 2024. if that's the worst case
scenario for Republicans that's the one
I want
on the other hand is a very
snipey and and a sort of a low brow
battle between Trump and DeSantis for
the Republican party for the next two
years the most damaging thing to
Republicans which will weaken them and
make them crumble and erode such that
they get crushed in 2024. that's my
concern whatever is the worst thing for
them is what I want to see happen right
now
it seems as though the infighting is
good for the left and good for Democrats
and Trump is already attacking Ron
DeSantis we'll talk about that a little
bit later and there are many reasons to
think that the Murdoch's now feeling
free to pull the rip cord is a good
thing we're going to talk about this
plenty more we're linking to the piece
by John pedora it's I know it's the New
York Post but the whole point is it's
interesting to see how even they now are
portraying Trump and specifically I now
want to talk about Pennsylvania